aquí hemos representado una economía en
equilibrio a largo plazo observa el
punto en el cual se intersectan la curva
de demanda agregada y la curva de oferta
agregada a corto plazo ese punto
especifica un nivel de equilibrio de los
precios en f1 y una producción de
equilibrio de uno pero ese punto también
intersec a la curva de oferta agregada a
largo plazo que es la producción cuando
tenemos pleno empleo recuerda que con la
producción de pleno empleo no nos
referimos a que todas las personas
dentro de una economía tienen empleo
sino que el nivel de empleo es
sostenible a eso nos referimos con pleno
empleo si por alguna razón la tasa de
desempleo disminuyera un poco de ese
nivel es decir que más gente trabajará o
se empleará tendríamos una situación
insostenible para esta economía pero en
este vídeo lo que realmente nos preocupa
es qué sucede si nuestra curva de
demanda agregada se desplaza que ocurre
en el corto y en el largo plazo
supongamos que hay todo tipo de noticias
positivas
demanda agregada se desplaza hacia
arriba vamos a desplazar nuestra curva
de demanda agregada
entonces se desplaza de esta manera de
pronto todo el mundo se ha vuelto más
optimista y dado el nivel de precios con
el que iniciamos la gente quiere
demandar más producción
entonces qué va a suceder en este
ejemplo bueno pues vamos a tener un
nuevo equilibrio a corto plazo ahora
estamos aquí vamos a llamar a esto np 2
nivel de precios 2 y este es de 2 el
nivel de producción 2 qué fue lo que
ocurrió
bueno pues podemos ver que a corto plazo
los precios van a aumentar los oferentes
de la producción van a decir toda esta
gente quiere mis productos así que ahora
voy a cobrar más por ellos y también voy
a incrementar la producción está
teniendo lugar un periodo de bonanza y
la gente no solo está demandando más
producción sino que está dispuesta a
pagar más por ella entonces en realidad
nuestra producción va a estar por encima
de la producción completa empleo
efe
tal vez el desempleo va a estar por
debajo del nivel sostenible porque en
vez de ir a la escuela o hacer cualquier
otra cosa
todas las personas van a conseguir
empleo los jubilados van a ponerse a
trabajar de nuevo porque está teniendo
lugar un periodo de bonanza pero qué va
a pasar a largo plazo bueno pues a largo
plazo la gente que esté trabajando va a
decir mi empresa está teniendo esta
bonanza cuando mi contrato laboral se
termine voy a pedir un aumento entonces
a medida que el precio del trabajo
aumente qué va a suceder con la curva de
oferta agregada a corto plazo pues
también se va a desplazar hacia arriba
es decir la curva de oferta agregada a
corto plazo va a disminuir vamos a
desplazarla mucho más arriba la gente va
a demandar cada vez más y más dinero
esto hará que nuestra oferta agregada a
corto plazo disminuya hasta el punto en
que alcancemos nuestro nivel de
producción sostenible de nuevo lo que
realmente sucedió fue que al principio
tuvimos este incremento de los precios y
la producción se incrementó más allá del
nivel sostenible
entonces la gente dijo no no no yo
quiero más dinero por mi tiempo así que
los salarios aumentaron y al ser un
costo para las empresas luego también
los precios aumentarán aún más pero si
los precios aumentan tanto incluso con
esta nueva curva de demanda agregada
desplazada la gente va a decir bueno tal
vez ya no quiero tanto de eso la
producción baja y entonces vamos a
regresar a este punto y si esta era la
demanda agregada 2b a 2 después de que
todo el mundo se sintiera optimista esta
va a ser el cp2 la oferta agregada a
corto plazo 2 ahora nuestro precio de
equilibrio
np 3 el nivel de precios 3 es bastante
más elevado pero estamos de vuelta en la
producción con pleno empleo y a esto lo
podemos llamar de 3 que es lo mismo que
lleva 1 el cual es igual a nuestra
producción con pleno empleo
efe
esto que acabamos de ver se conoce como
el mecanismo de corrección a largo plazo
es un argumento que a veces los
economistas usan con este modelo
simplificado para decir si estás en una
situación por encima o por debajo de tu
producción con pleno empleo
no te preocupes se corregirá por sí
misma a largo plazo y tal vez el
gobierno no tenga que intervenir en
próximos vídeos hablaremos sobre cómo el
gobierno puede intervenir en cualquiera
de los dos casos pero lo que este
argumento nos está diciendo es que a
corto plazo las cosas pueden desviarse
de la producción con pleno empleo pero
que a largo plazo existen mecanismos
naturales que le permitirán a la
producción volver a su potencial natural
la producción con pleno empleo hasta el
próximo vídeo